in the last handful of years
what have you become better at saying no
to could be distractions invitations
anything are there any new realizations
or approaches that have have helped you
to
say no to more maybe that's not even a
problem you have but i figured i would
ask
no i have a problem saying no and i've
definitely become better at saying no
you know in some cases i just don't have
the time
but it is a problem i mean the problem
is i'm a people pleaser like i want to
please the people in front of me whoever
they are sometimes even if they are a
random stranger emailing me some stuff i
still i'm a people pleaser so
this is not that new but it is a big
trick that i learned a little while ago
specifically for invitations and stuff
like that which is
i used to say yes to an invitation to
like give a talk
next year
just go give a talk next year and i
usually say yes because i thought next
year i won't be that busy
or whatever like and just if you change
your framing whenever somebody asks you
to do something a long time from now
change the framing and say what if it
was tomorrow
would you want to do this or not
almost invariably the answer is no i
definitely don't want to do this
tomorrow
and then you should answer based on that
yeah and i think that has helped me say
no to a lot of things where you just say
like okay because
it's not necessarily a trick that people
use although sometimes maybe it is a
trick but
you know when you i just get asked to do
certain things months from now and i
never think about
man
i'm actually gonna have to do it and
it's gonna suck i just never think about
that so i'm just like yeah months from
now it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
you really
you really should get a lot better at
that and just think about
what if it was tomorrow what are the
areas of your life right now that you'd
like to change the most and why
i i would like to be
less
i i like to be less time-bound i like to
be less
greedy about signing up for things i
don't know how to describe this you know
what it really is i had a tweet recently
where i was going back and forth with
somebody and then came up with this
concept of uh there should be a
two-factor authentication on your
calendar
all right we have two factors
exactly for this two-factor
authentication when you're logging into
a website that
if your password gets stolen the
attacker doesn't the thief or hacker
doesn't have your phone so they can't
log in because the phone has to generate
a unique code well i wish there was a
two-factor code against my calendar
because
current me present me is always making
promises for future me currently is
tired exhausted hungry wants to go home
wants to go to sleep wants to read a
book wants to hang out with the wife and
baby
but future me is this dynamic high
energy individual who will always show
up to every meeting and we'll have a lot
of energy and we'll want to get a lot of
things done so i commit myself to all
these commitments in the future that
when the future of me arrives it's
actually just present me yes back to
being lazy and hungry and tired so i
want a two factor against myself uh and
the way i would like to do that is i
think every time i make a commitment to
anything i should instead just write it
down and then check back in 48 hours
later and then clear mine and say do i
commit to doing this or even better
would be saying if i commit doing
something then i can commit to doing it
right now yeah i think if i'm not
willing to do it right now but don't do
it don't commit to it yeah that's the
derek sivers approach right like if
you're not saying hell yes right now
then you should just be saying no i
think
yeah so i think this is this is
something of every busy person i just
want to be much better at managing my
own time because you go through life
through an exploration phase and then
you switch to an exploitation phase and
i'm very much in the exploitation phase
i'm not looking for more exploration
but that all that said i have a hard
time saying no if i mean if i had one
wish the most important thing to me
would be i would constantly be running
my mind in debug mode i would literally
be watching every single thought i have
and letting no
no
reaction pass
without it being stopped inspected
stripped searched examined understood
and then let go but the reality that
there's a lot of time
and we're just highly conditioned
creatures so i i do
view a lot of my goals over the next few
years of unconditioning previous learned
responses or habituated responses
so that i can make decisions more
cleanly in the moment without relying
upon memory or or pre-packaged
heuristics and judgments
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you